we're going to begin with those murders
in Idaho the new details about the man
accused of killing four students at the
University of Idaho suspect Brian
coburger appeared in an Idaho courtroom
for the very first time yesterday and in
newly unsealed court documents police
say they identified him getting into the
details also getting into how they
linked him to the crime scene also a
chilling affidavit alleges that one of
the surviving roommates saw a masked man
she did not know walked past her bedroom
door the morning of the murders Omar
villafranca has more now from Moscow
Idaho but a warning here in a quadruple
murder story some of these details are
disturbing
murder suspect Brian coburger smiled at
his public defender as he faced a judge
in Idaho for the first time Thursday
alleges that you committed
committed first degree the maximum
penalty for that offense if you plead
guilty or are found guilty is up to
death and or imprisonment for life do
you understand yes
charged with stabbing Kaylee gonsalves
Madison Mogan Zannah kernodle and Ethan
Chapin to death in the early morning
hours of November 13th according to a
newly unsealed 18-page affidavit
investigators discovered DNA on a knife
sheath similar to this one found on the
bed next to Madison Mogan they linked
that DNA to co-burger by matching it to
his father's DNA found in the trash
outside the family home the knife sheath
left at the crime scene which is where
they derived the DNA to me is like a
nail in the coffin Casey Jordan a
criminologist with no connection to the
case believes the evidence against
co-burger is overwhelming citing
stunning new details in the affidavit
from an interview with the surviving
roommate she told investigators she woke
up around 4am and thought she heard
Kaylee gonsalves say there's someone
here later the roommate said she heard
what sounded like crying in Zana
kernodles room then a male voice say
something to the effect of it's okay I'm
going to help you when she opened her
bedroom door she told investigators she
saw a man she did not recognize wearing
black clothes and a mask she described
him as 5 10 or taller male not very
muscular but athletically built with
bushy eyebrows she said she stood Frozen
as the man walked by her to the back
door she then went in her room and
locked the door the affidavit did not
explain why police were not called to
the scene until noon about eight hours
later I really do believe that the
evidence is so strong already where the
investigation is complete he's going to
have an uphill climb to try to be found
not guilty
it's worth noting that investigators
laid out several threads tying coburger
to the crime scene police say his cell
phone pinged in the area of the crimes
at least a dozen times before the
attacks police also say that a white
Hyundai was seen speeding away after the
attack he drives a wide Hyundai from
there police say that they were able to
track that car's toll tag from
Washington State all the way to
Pennsylvania there in Pennsylvania they
got a DNA sample from his parents trash
bin that DNA sample linked back to the
knife sheath found here in Idaho a lot
of police work was going on he will
remain here in the Lata County Jail
he'll be in court next week where he'll
enter a plea Tony yeah wow I mean it
took some time for police to get that
evidence but there's a lot in this
indictment Omar thank you very much in
our next hour 48 Hours correspondent
Peter Van Sant will join us with a
closer look at the suspect and also
he'll be sharing some new information
from coburger's friends and colleagues